何かご質問など はい 妄想で今日も来ていただいたんですけど
本当に妄想を断ち切るのは
今言われたように もう瞬間瞬間のサティということ
例えばあの掃除なんかやってても
もう本当に集中するもんですから
他の方は何も忘れて没頭するような気持ちになるのですが
それではなくて やっぱり
だからあの 集中するときは妄想はしてないんで
とにかく しかし この仏教でいうこの厳密な妄想していないっていう意味じゃないんです
だからこの それはもう集中っていうことで
気分がいいんですよ 体には悪くないんです
何にでも徹底的に良いことですけどね
集中すれば 人殺しに徹底的に集中しちゃうと意味がないんですけどね
で 気分もいいし 健康的にもなるし
幸せも感じる で だからもう何でもいいんだから良いものに集中するっていうことは推薦はする
サティっていうのは この別なこの智慧開発するための機能で
実況中継ということをして
とにかく心に妄想させないという強引なやり方で妄想させないで置いておくと
やがて慣れてしまっちゃうんですよ
妄想しないことに それでも才能は抜群
だからヴィパッサナーはこのまちまちにやってる人は結構才能を発揮するでしょ
ちょっとやっただけでも
そんなに真剣にやらなくても
ちょっとまちまちにやったっても
結構才能が出てくる 若い頃だったらもうどうせもういい加減まちまちでしょうに
でもやったら結構いい結果が出る
他の人ことは聞かないでください
なんで一生懸命やってる人は
とにかく僕は結果論です
結果がなければやってないっていうことにするんです
はい はいはい  あの  ちょっと大きい声で
えーと 以前長老が何事であっても驚いてはいけないようなことをおっしゃったと思うんですけども
今 ニュースでいろいろこう
例えばあの大学に米軍のヘリコプターが落ちたとか
あるいはインターネットで日本人の人質の人が首を切られている映像が流れてるとか
驚かないといけないようなニュースが流れてるんですが
そういう部分も全然驚かないで
ただ殺されたんですか？と
こう なんていうのかな
ヘリコプターが落ちたんですか？とか
こう簡単に認識というか
してないといけないかどうか
ちょっとわからない  うんうん
あれ 今あのあの驚かないと
あの無関心ということと
ちょっとごちゃになってるんです
で 何があっても驚かないではなくて
驚くことはありませんと
すべて自然法則で因果法則なんですよ
ヘリコプターはちょうど学校の上で故障しちゃうと
そちらには落ちないで
なんでちゃんとヘリコプター着陸するところに着陸できるのかってありえないでしょ
だからその自体 因果法則で見ると驚くべきことではないんです
だから無関心って言ったらちょっとね
だから驚くこと あ なんだこれ
なんでこんなことあるのかと
ただかなり興奮して驚くだけで
例えば仏教的に見れば
もう人は残酷に殺されているんだとかね
例えば日本人は一人を首を飛んじゃったと
でもあまりコマーシャル宣伝材料にならないんだから
コマーシャルのマスコミと政府はそれは全くきれいさっぱり無視しているんだと
自分の利益になるんだから
前のケースの場合は大騒ぎしたでしょ
こうやって考えてみれば
人間の人間が誰であろうとも
自分の利益でしか動いてないんではないかと
人が亡くなることは心配とか世間でないんではないかとか
非常に考えたって悪くないと思いますよ
例えば学校で元気で健康で遊ぶとふざけて楽しく遊んでいても
ヘリが落ちてくる可能性もあります
だから命は儚いものであると
そういう風には感じるんですよ
昔 エピソードもあります
あるお坊さんたちがお釈迦様から瞑想を教えてもらって山に入ったんですよ
でお釈迦様から直々指導を受けたんだから
案終わると必ず悟るはずなんです
で このお坊さんたち悟らなかったんです
それで考えたのは しまったと
我々は何か間違っている
一生懸命頑張ったんだけど
悟らなかった もう一度お釈迦様のところに行きましょう
で 道場を全部畳んで お釈迦様に会って
もう一度指導を賜わりましょうと
指導というのは一回切りなんですけど
本当は で 戻ってきたんです
戻ってくる途中で 山火事にあったんです
すいなり火が上がってきて
さーっと枯れた葉っぱ
草やらも燃やして ざーっと燃えて燃えていっちゃったんですね
そこを見たある一人のお坊さんが驚いちゃったっていうかね
もう感心したんですよ
なんでたちまち瞬間に火が物事を燃やして消していくのでしょうかと
で 同時に我々心の煩悩もたちまち燃やさなくちゃあかんではないかと
といって そこで無常を見て感動して
普通に驚いちゃって その出来事に
で 仏教的に見たところで
そこで悟ったんです で
また行くと で この雨が降って
このちょっと水が流れてるんですね
そこで水がものすごい勢いでこの石から落ちたりするんです
その水の流れで あるもう一人のお坊さんが
では顔でも洗って水を飲もうと思ったところで
この水が落ちて落ちて泡が立つ
泡が立つんだけどね 水の泡だから立っては壊れる
立っては壊れる 立っては
これじっと驚いて見ていたんです
見てたところで 自分の体も全ての現象も生まれては消える
生まれては消える 生まれては消えるということをじりじり感じちゃって
悟ってしまったんです
そこでもう一人はこの蜃気楼もあったんですね
また結構遠かったみたいですからね
で 歩いてると蜃気楼見える
で 歩いてそちら辺に行ったらまた蜃気楼がないんです
もっと遠くある そこで何やこれと
それで幻想であって で
我々のあるのごとく見えるだけやということで
そのお坊さんも悟る それで結局
お釈迦様にて修行をやり直しましょうと言ったっても
三人ともお釈迦様ありがとうございます
もう修行完成しましたという言葉になっちゃったんです
ブッダの指導に間違いはないんだから
だから そのエピソードで驚いたっていう意味でもいいんですよ
我々はキャーキャーキャーキャーと驚いたっても
これはもうもうもうカラスの生き方で何の意味もないんです
世の中にはあるべきものしか起こりません
しかし その中から我々は何かを学ばなくちゃいけない
ただ ですから無関心は良くない
だからといってあまり感心しすぎちゃって困っても良くない
日本人は首は切られたんだけど
これは誠に残念なことで
だからってそれ以上我々には何もできません
逆にイラク人もどれぐらい殺されているのか
自分の国でね 考えちゃうと
まあそれぞれいろんなことを考えられますよ
まあとにかくこのお 驚いちゃうっていうことは興奮しちゃって頭が混乱したっていうことで
びっくりした 感動したっていうことは別にそれほどのことではないんですが
因果法則で見るとはびっくりもないんですけどね
一応我々は常に何かを学ばなくちゃいけないっていうことだけはあります
だから無関心 言葉の使い方によりますけど
この一番悪い意味でいう無関心ということはよくないんですね
リミットを超えて関心を持つということはよくない
また いわゆる興味を持つ
それだけ 無関心ではなくてね
興味を持つと結構勉強もできますしね
新聞 雑誌 本も読めるし
読んだものは覚えてもいられるし
覚えていたって苦痛にはならないしね
だから興味を持つっていうことはすごくいいことで
でもやりすぎはダメって何でも
はい まあそれぐらいしか意見は言えないんですけど
こうのも この三宝に帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖先 親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サンベティーヨ ヴィワンジャントゥ
サンバローゴーウィナッサトゥ
マーテーバワトアンタラーヨ
スキーディーガーユコーバワ
バワトゥサンバマンガラン
ラッカントゥサンバデーヴァータサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナ
サンバダンマヌバーヴェーナ
サンバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ
サダースッティバワントテ
アビワダナシーリッサニッチャンワッダパチャイノ
チャッターロダンマワッダンティーアーユアンノウ
スカンバラン  長い時間本当にありがとうございます
ありがとうございます